welcome to ball hatak in Belgium no both
of the bar on the South in the
Netherlands boots Belgium okay everyone
please calm down
it's both welcome to the town with one
of the most intricate borders in the
whole world
[Music]
Baro is a quiet small town with not much
going on until you look at these crosses
yep that's an international border and
so is that and so is that barlas home to
a living border puzzle instead of one
border crossing there are dozens of them
and that's because the town consists of
30 enclaves there are 22 pieces of
Belgium surrounded by the Netherlands
and 10 dust areas in Belgium the border
goes through houses shops beer stores
and this means that there are two of
almost everything for a population of
under 10,000 two postal service's to
churches to bus companies to legal
drinking ages there are even two mayo
toppings at this chicken shop yep this
one Dutch and this one's Belgium and
there's two town halls and of course a
meeting room with a border line in it
and two separate representatives
so how did the town get into this messy
situation a safe text market minutes
filleted and m12 the air would exchange
from a friend Hector from rabbits and
Road daily from that'll be two over two
hey Fleur and here from breda Elphaba
charming and later on this meant that
the Duke of Brabant possessed Belgian
lands and the Lord of Breda Dutch lands
as your installed LED halyard artistry
diversity impersonating ravenous and
Carranza what for shield passage tells
so austere new from diagonal state stamp
cylinder you mean this talking with her
esophagus listening she tapped over they
here I should have over for lifting I
should have done 30 no leering that
would have examined my sinuses here Mase
it's failing
got it so head of tourism Willem how do
you know where your house is
if the border goes through it we have a
four door rule and the front of home say
is there where your front door is that
is the place where you have your double
CD anyway while you're living in Holland
but what about front doors that get
chopped off by the border like this one
that's an exception living there you you
can choose the about wastrels like
gallery owner Sylvia this is Belgium
this is Netherlands and this is my
gallery I have chosen from Belgium
because I was living in Belgium my
company was about you so I take the
easiest way alright but the
International commute it must be tiring
right cafe manager William of course my
Cafe is at the Dutch side
I am Belgian so across the border every
day but I live here too will not meet us
from so it's not that far
ok so my last question it has to be this
which town is best borrow hair tug or
borrow NASA
I prefer boats I'm Dutch and to be
honest I like the way of living more in
the belt inside
[Laughter]
[Music]
in the end it doesn't matter which side
of the border you choose all in all this
is just a great love story between two
countries have everyone open for hand
side bar at the bottom of or we'll send
for candidacy two hostages but here is a
goal for the problem is that we have
learned to deal with each other we have
learned to live with each other and I
could say your example for the rest of
[Music]
hi I'm Sophia I've produced this piece
and we've also produced other pieces
about very quirky towns and one of them
is below